>> Jon: YOU KNOW, WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S SPEECH LAST NIGHT
BUT FOR EVERY STATE OF THE
UNION, WHICH I THINK IS THE
LAW OF FISIC, THERE MUST
ALSO BE THE POST SPEECH
OPPOSITION RESPONSE.
AND I'M EXCITED ABOUT IT.
IT MEANS IT'S TIME TO HAND
OUT THIS YEAR'S IMPLODE
YEAST.
FOR OUTSTANDING ACHIEVEMENT
IN UNFORCED RESPONSE SPEECH
ERROR, PREVIOUS WINNERS
INCLUDE DRY LIPS McGEE.
AND CRAZY EYES WHERE I DO
LOOK?
AND OLD BOBBY [BLEEP] I'M
GOING TO JAIL.
SO WHO IS GOING HOME WITH
THE IMPLODIE THIS YEAR?
>> JONI ERNST IS GIVING THE
REPUBLICAN SPORS.
>> A TEA PARTY FAVORITE.
>> VERY STRONG.
>> INSTANT GOP ROCK STAR.
>> A WOMAN WHO RIDES A
HARLEY.
>> SHE GREW UP CASS
STRAIGHT-- CASTRATING PIGS.
>> TRYING TO MAKE THEM
SQUEAL IN WASHINGTON.
>> Jon: OH MAN, GOP IS
BRINGING THE FUNK.
WITHOUT BETTER THAN A HOG
BALL BULL DOZEIN SQUEAL
GENERATING HARLEY'S ANGEL TO
GRAB THE ATTENTION WITH
VITALITY OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
TAKE IT AWAY, SENATOR.
>> GROW-- GROWING UP, HI
ONLY ONE GOOD PAIR OF SHOES.
SO ON RAINY SCHOOL DAYS, MY
MOM WOULD SLIP PLASTIC BREAD
BAGS OVER THEM, BUT I WAS
NEVER EMBARRASSED.
BECAUSE THE SCHOOL BUS WOULD
BE FILLED WITH ROWS AND ROWS
OF YOUNG IOWAANS WITH BREAD
BAGS SLIPPED OVER THEIR FEET.
>> Jon: IS THAT YOU, SIRI?
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Jon: YOU KNOW, THAT
SEEMED LIKE LESS OF A
RESPONSE TO THE PRESIDENT'S
ADDRESS THAN AN APPLICATION
ESSAY TO NOSTALGIA
UNIVERSITY.
NOSTALGIA UNIVERSITY, IT WAS
BETTER WHEN YOUR DAD WENT
THERE.
WHAT IS ERNST TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH BY TELLING HERR
ORIGIN STORY.
>> HER JOB WAS TO HUMANIZE
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: WELL, IF HER JOB WAS
TO HUMANIZE THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, MISSION ACCOMPLISHED.
ALL RIGHT.
SO THAT WAS THE REPUBLICAN
RESPONSE.
AND I GUESS BECAUSE SHE'S
THE TEA PARTY SWEETHEART, IT
COUNTS AS A TEA PARTY
RESPONSE AS WELL.
SO I GUESS WE'RE DONE.
THAT'S ALL-- CONDITIONS CURT
CLAWSON GIVING THE TEA PARTY
RESPONSE.
>> Jon: WHAT?
I THOUGHT 14E WAS THE
TEA-- ALL RIGHT, I GUESS HE
BETTER HAVE SOMETHING PRETTY
IMPORTANT TO SAY TO JUSTIFY
A SEPARATE OFFICIAL
RESPONSE.
>> DECADES AGO I PLAYED
BASKETBALL AT PURDUE.
WE HAD A GUARD FROM THE WEST
COAST, A FORWARD FROM GARY,
A POST PLAYER FROM
CINCINNATI,.
>> Jon: A SMALL-- FROM
TIJUANA AN ASSISTANT COACH
FROM THE THIRD MOON OF
JUPITER.
AND WE HAD A JEWISH WATER
BOY WITH SOME KIND OF SPEECH
IMPEDIMENT.
IT ALL WENT-- ALL RIGHT.
INSPIRING BASKETBALL MELTING
POT ANECDOTE DELIVERED.
THOSE WERE THE TWO TEA PARTY
RESPONSES AND WE'RE DONE.
SO THAT'S --
>> RAND PAUL IS GIVING ON
HIS OWN YOUTUBE CHANNEL A
RESPONSE.
>> LIBERAL ELITES FLY OVER
MY SMALL TOWN BUT THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND US.
THEY SIMPLY SEEK TO IMPOSE
THEIR WILL UPON US.
>> Jon: LIBERAL ELITES?
YOU'RE A DOCTOR AND A
SENATOR WITH A 12-TERM
CONGRESSMAN FATHER AND A
FIRST NAME SYNONYMOUS WITH A
RUSSIAN NOVELIST?
THAT'S PRETTY [BLEEP] ELITE.
SO I GUESS THE ENGINEER HERE,
LIBERAL, FINE, WE GOT THE
RESPONSE TO THE TEA PARTY
RESPONSE.
I ASSUME THAT'S ALL.
>> A RESPONSE FROM ANOTHER
POTENTIAL PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE TED CRUZ.
>> Jon: HOW MANY [BLEEP]
PEOPLE ARE AT THIS TEA PARTY?
AND WHAT DID THIS GUY PUT ON
HIS FEET WHEN IT RAINED.
>> MEDIAN INCOMES HAVE
STAGNATED FOR OVER A DECADE.
>> LET ME START OVER.
(APPLAUSE)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Jon: HERE'S A TIP.
IF ARE YOU LOOKING TO RUN
FOR PRESIDENT, MAYBE YOU
SHOULDN'T MAKE YOUR RESPONSE
TO THE STATE OF THE UNION
LOOK LIKE A RANSOM VIDEO.
(LAUGHTER)
OR THE PART OF THE PORNO
EVERYBODY FAST TOWARDS
THROUGH.
SENATOR CRUZ, I PRESENT TO
YOU THIS YEAR'S IMPLODIE.
I WOULD LET YOU GIVE AN
ACCEPTANCE SPEECH BUT NAH.